الى اتهامات تويتر لشركه متى باستنساخ
خصائص من تويتر وبنقلها الى تطبيق التي
اعادت للاذهان اتهامات سابقه لمتى بهذا
الخصوص المقارنات بين تويتر بدات منذ
اطلاق التطبيق الاخير الذي راى فيه
مستخدمون وحتى ايلون ماسك انه تقليد
لتويتر وهدد بمقاظات متى وللسخريه من
الامر نشر مارك زوكربيرج نفسه تغريده في
اشاره الى التطبيق الى التشابه في
التطبيقين بوضع شخصيتين تمثلان
يشير كل منهما للاخر متخصصون بشؤون
التقنيه يشيرون لوجود تاريخ طويل من
المحاكاه لدى زاكربيرج عبر استنساخ بعض
الافكار من تطبيقات اخرى واستخدامها في
التطبيقات التابعه لمتى من بين الافكار
نقل خدمات تطبيقات المواعده لتطبيق
المواعده الخاص بفيسبوك فيسبوك فيسبوك
ديتنج باعلان صقر بيرج ان التطبيق سيخدم
بناء علاقات طويله وحقيقيه الا انه لم
يستمر وفي عام 2016 قدم تطبيق انستجرام
التابع لماده خاصيه هي خاصيه الاستوريز
والتي انها منقوله عن سناب شات كما نقل
الى انستجرام ايضا مرشحات او فلترات
الوجوه من الافكار المنقوله ايضا الى
انستجرام خاصيه الريلز والتي بدات في تيك
توك وعندما كشفت انستجرام عن هذه الميزه
عرض التقديم عشره الاف دولار لبعض مصممي
المحتوى لنشر مقاطعهم المصوره وفي هذه او
في هذا العام وفر تطبيق المراسله واتساب
للمستخدمين امكانيه تعديل الرسائل بعد ما
يصل الى 15 دقيقه من ارسالها وهي ميزه
كانت موجوده لدى تطبيقات مثل سيجنال
والتليجرام اخيرا استنسخت فيسبوك من شركه
نكس دور وهي شركه امريكيه تعمل على تشغيل
خدم خدمه شبكات اجتماعيه للاحياء السكنيه
من خلال فكره احياء فيسبوك او فيسبوك
اذا من خلال فكره هذه الاحياء التي روج
لها على انها مساحه تواصل مع الجيران
والمجتمع المحلي لكن تم اغلاقها العام
الماضي لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات